watch this
that's Joni or it's right there what
John thune senator
veraso
watch how he walks
look he has no idea these are the people
making decisions for all for us and our
future and our kids future you have the
other video of him and him being
escorted away I think it's right here's
Senator Johnson just you know
tapping in of course finishing the
speech
yeah it was like the alien inside of his
head rebooted here's this one I'm
walking away
being escorted
Pat you see that he's how old how old is
he 81. 81 years old he's 81. uh Joe
Biden's 80. Pelosi's 83 Maxine Waters is
84. Chuck Grassley Is 89. Dianne
Feinstein is 90. she doesn't even know
who or where she is Carl Schwab 85
stores 92 the Robbie composite is that
like okay when people talk about term
let's if there is there no way to change
the fact that this is showing you like
they're falling apart in front of our
eyes John Stewart gave a Talk 11 months
ago right in front of it where he said
these [__] are 200 years old
they're like turtles they're here they
said guess what here's the thing that
both the left and the right agree on
yeah finally term limits guess what make
it work okay make it work to get term
limits in for this now that's not like
an overnight thing good luck getting
that in yeah uh because it's more
working the other way around you know
when you see stuff like this did you
know in 2010 uh uh they passed the law
so to allow corporations to have an open
checkbook on how much money they can
pretty much give to a campaign like do
you know how much money we all of a
sudden started putting into presidential
campaigns because it was a it was an
open shot have you seen this chart
before or no campaign Finance can you
send me that image that shows exactly
how much money was put into campaigns
from you know 2008 to 2012 16 2020. I'd
like to take a guess there's no cap
there was no cap no 2010 they opened it
up to say unlimited amount that you can
put in and now don't get me wrong
Supreme Court I believe yeah a lot of
Supreme Court ruling that if you can if
Brandon is watching Brandon I know you
are if you can just send me the pig for
me to show it to Rob uh uh um uh let me
see if he's I know he's emailed it to me
but go ahead if you're watching this
year Tom you see McConnell react that
way what do you think about well I think
about the citizens united 2019 Citizens
United and that's what you all can go
Google and look up Supreme Court
decision uh where John Roberts wrote the
major already positioned it basically
took campaign Finance it used to be hey
check this box on your tax return if
you'd like a dollar one dollar to go to
the the presidential election fund
number one and then there's limits you
could only give so much each year or
each election there were limits citizens
united basically uncapped corporate and
it took everything away so it's all
special interests that control it and
what what is special interest and the
uncapped corporations want they got to
keep their puppets Pat and their puppets
are 90 year old mummies walking around
yeah by the way somehow citizens united
has a Google uh
what's it called when you can give
ratings Google ratings all that okay
yeah they're 1.8 that's right it's a
non-profit organization email Brandon
says he emailed it to you so so
basically Pat the person with the most
money giving to the
to these people wins it's just the
richest person gets the most influence
over who they want yeah I mean that's
insane and by the way listen to the how
they the logic of the Supreme Court
there's only one sentence you have to
listen to it yeah the Court held 5-4
that freedom of speech Clause of the
First Amendment prohibits the government
from restricting independent
expenditures for political campaigns by
corporations including non-profits labor
unions and associations what of that's
why the criticism of it is wait you used
freedom of speech you're classified
money
and unlimited campaign donations and by
the way you know who wanted this every
member of Congress wanted this because
the special interest because I'm an oil
man you're a Pharma man you're an
agriculture man and you're a uh you're a
healthcare woman you're known by your
number one
and what you carry oh if you've ever
heard the um it's a a great phrase oh
you're Israel's guy on the hill and when
they say things like that oh yeah there
you go check this out this is how much
money presidential campaign financing 79
to 2020. it was only 197 million in 1979
80 then it went to 226 380 nothing crazy
346 478 612 891 Obama 1.769 billion
dollars and 1.46 1.529 Trump Biden look
at that if four billion dollars more
than the three previous elections
combined they spent everything they had
to terminate and fire Trump that's how
bad they wanted to get rid of them so
corporations came together and said
listen Open checkbook man here's someone
let's get rid of this guy this guy's
draining a swamp and we can no longer do
our deals that we were doing this guy
making our life a little bit hard boom
look how
there's never been a greater increase on
wanting to either elect somebody or get
rid of somebody than Trump that's a
great look at look at Obama Obama raised
that kind of money because it was a
dream it was the first time in U.S
history man we want to see this look at
the second one he dropped off he's the
only guy that for re-election his money
dropped off that's not a reflection of
Obama being a bad thing it's just the
fact that they really really wanted him
to win the first Samurai but they really
really yeah what a great point
before Trump uh Clinton what was the
closest presidential race prior to that
it was Bush yeah 2000 Gore Bush 612
million dollars was spent yeah
612. well we all know they used to use
the b word point they used to use the b
word when they're printed money billions
now it's all about the trillions
it was 2019 by the way citizens united
Supreme Court decision 2019. boom well
it's no wonder if you just follow the
money we just talked about it the other
day on the podcast
five out of the top 10 richest counties
in the country are all in what city
Washington DC watch all the money right
all the lobbyist money it's all the
campaign Finance money it's all going
there but back to Mitch McConnell
because how this whole thing started
look obviously the guy's not well you
know and generally I'm not a Mitch
McConnell fan but I hope he's doing well
time to step aside you know the only
answer to term limits right because
everyone wants term limits but you know
you know who who needs to vote on term
limits uh the Congress people they're
not going to do it so the only answer to
that is actually voting these incapable
vegetables out of office so it's
incumbent on the constituents
constituents people love it to vote
something like this up so someone in
Kentucky was like yep I want six more
years of McConnell and this is what you
get
it's almost like the alien in him was
like rebooting like yeah so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]